now yeah you know we're legislative
change Darrin Austin Oregon Legislature
will change like a new people don't have
to build court battles you know
legislation and litigation of agitation
these are the sort of strategies
education we're still heavily involved
in education denim does not you know we
still have some ability to write rules
regulating this stuff like we could
write an evacuation plan which is good
because we've had several fires and
blowouts we're helping the city work on
that but basically now the story
continues and then I weren't just and I
was going to light up the a fictional
sequel to the story that was from delve
into the depths that are just under the
surface here and then this will be my
last note
there are some people I don't know
honestly where I follow this that think
that Frankie and work against fossil
fuels or the fight upon tunt and
enlightenment fighter extreme measures
and so I don't know what's going to
happen you see I think I see the
beginnings public incredibly powerful
movement of closed halt and it
intersects with it but even I did was
about a land-use policy and not so much
on energy policy there's a powerful
interesting intersection stronger along
around it was definitely to the elevator
so it's my kind of to be continuing but
I think I'll leave it there open up
folks want to ask questions what I was
told to use the microphone so this
[Music]
I understand you think that the art
method making primarily let community
decide what they do I do not want an
economic activity in your face it's
probably heavy industrial activity the
suburban community that was not a place
and maybe a place like southern tier New
York myself this year making those
because they're very economically
we want that sorry saying it could go
either way and they lock but the
community wants me to stay fracking is
just a bad thing
great question and I think that's that
question you bide certain people that I
work closely with so I'll just give you
my only take on that and it was really
also the tape of our campaign which is
the former or two options essentially
what our message was let the communities
decide for yourself you know and if it
didn't make sense for a lot of reasons
we were trapped with these old laws it's
also not an economic driver for us even
industries all the figures showed the
tracking which was possible to me about
0.2 percent of our jobs
yes the one person in our local economy
it's not worth it for us but I recognize
with other communities where a baby were
and so the my big principle behind this
which I'm an identity and that story's a
student of mine that performers do like
we called it the lower abeyance and we
said let the folks who are most horrible
to the risks and harms have the greatest
Salem ever
and that's kind of what I mean by opt
for let the communities who have to live
there
decide whether or not they wanna else
beside under what conditions because of
fracking
can have all different layers of
regulations and all different kinds of
technologies we all do and so a
community could say we might get with XY
and Z but not a HC right so that's kind
of why school
others
those photographs all right that's good
which part yeah you leave the fracking
probably incredible run by responsible
companies
environment
mr. man i necessary in my responsible I
conclude
sensible standoff
yeah so I think that I like the way to
phrase the question let's be on the
party and then because your phrasing was
with the band haven't handed in my
responsible operations going on I think
the expats know it wouldn't happen you
know we haven't we now have about 290
gas was in our city limits before we
even thought about Manny we already had
250 people were living basically right
it was just getting more goes in closer
and closer to people and operate from
saying you know any summer so I think
there was a sense of again that we could
have no habitated with this we can find
a way but we'd have to give give give
that's really what like that's that's a
times of your question that's another
reason I think community should decide
find something because you'll have two
operators in you know the whole basis if
you've got some bad words you can either
back
[Music]
thank you now that HP party is affecting
cities all over the state of not just
Hampton do you see the rumors are
expanding outside of sentences for
communications in cooperation with other
cities over is such an onerous law that
cities are really trying to like that
[Music]
you know I'm you from Texas no no
recruit you into the network before
because your your question is prescient
we all were forming a grassroots network
of communities representatives from
these communities and right now I just
be talking personally I think kind of a
guerrilla style warfare is the best
which is don't have a solid stable
identity just be sort of all over the
place and then that's starting to happen
more communities are getting energized
about that if there's a silver lining
around 80 40 is this very issue that
it's kind of been a wake-up call for
other groups that I think I've been
assuming well we can fix this the
narrative that our time and now excited
unless you know determination for it so
yeah it's it's going viral across the
state but we'll see it's even like that
it's hard to eat this legislature
it's very much her own bio oil gas and
HB 40 unfortunately casting a lot of
limits so we have to overturn models
I guess I just want to delve a little
deeper into that and ask you know how do
you see the political climate evolving
in the wake of HB 40 in Pennsylvania had
at 13 and after the passage I think it
was very similar law in turn to take
away rights from communities and I think
out a salute to that it was actually a
considerable backlash from
municipalities and when people realized
what the content of that legislation was
and you know it sounds like you've seen
the beginnings of that Texas but where
do you see that do you see that becoming
the larger movement about a great
question yeah and help me out if I get
some details wrong could be no better
idea but act 13 was a similar law in
Pennsylvania and it led to a backlash
which then led to a partial repeal of
parts of X 13 and particularly the stuff
that has to do with Home Rule Authority
that's exactly what we mean and I hope
you're right that was through starting
that process the problem in Texas well
in Pennsylvania there is a as far as I
understand there's a state amendment
that constitutional amendment that gives
communities very high standard real
estate and gives health and safety
protections a very strong vacuum that
Texas doesn't have
and so as far as I understood that
partial repeal about 30 million even on
these constitutional Hamas and state
constitutional of year which Texas
doesn't have so we're going to find I
think a different strategy in one thing
that somebody lovely blacks we
introduced to a petition to repeal HB 40
and the problem is that states doesn't
have a petition of the process can
happen so you can't do that yeah well I
guess that the Paula questions I mean do
you think they're going to be able to
organize I mean do you think there's no
gay enough popularity of local control
of the local level
you know this legislation that may
change
I let me put coming up look into the
crystal ball and say yes so here's why
this is one scenario it's in playing out
we're building a massive scale gas
export facilities mostly most of the
money of sort of Texas is piano
[Music]
[Music]
Jesus hand together
but it's my understanding that we're
going to see a lot of exporting of
natural gas to European and Asian
markets the Asian American markets
you know fluctuates so much more than
drawing that 15 dollars per Mcf and
right
do you know about three or four bucks
here three or four with you prior so
we're more like some is he seven well
yeah but what I could see happening is
we start exporting this stuff the
activity picks up right now there's
really no drilling activity to speak oh
it'll pick up because the price will go
up I don't know whose price parity in
those markets or not but we're kind of
international I say some people is just
a domestic market prices well activity
goes up frustrations and communities
build up drives political action and I
think with those sort of kindlin
conditions I think we're going to see
clearly change but only you would take
that
which is not a phrase
this is a extension of my earlier like
this was head-on collision between two
people that you represent and the
industry from here hoarded if the
industry I don't know it's a good
question could it be avoided
it's a Guinness and speculation
like yes
in all together it depends it and what I
think depends on is the kind of
opposition means we must strengthen
because what I what I recognize the
rooted coalesced around coalesced around
the band some of them were actually
saying as I I don't mind really
I just know on my backyard and I'm
singing the limiter my dad worked in the
oil industry but nobody took boots off
before
there's a place for it and others say no
. we have to have herself or not mean
arsenal topic just cut the umbilical
cord
now the one who will listen to a more
reasonable operation in Canada laughter
they don't have a exist functional
acquisition ask the other report
it's right there
but
yes that's them
just finish
that's weird
others ya know I was curious what
challenges you guys space regards to
traction on this boat big money in
politics and an entire party at half the
country that Nona
some of the negatives around fracking so
ya know issued by fracking does those
two things team call that's more okay
the politics of this were very
interested in Hartley in some ways in
your life so the strategy was to not
talk about climate change law it's we've
got a climate change issue this was
about sensible man who's playing about
what happens in your neighborhood and so
that I think the boy did a lot of what
would have been unnecessary flashing
over that issue some were very
self-conscious about not messaging and
and sort of the normal terms is a local
issue affect our best with our health
our safety powered about the other part
of your question
Oh fracking there's so much much worse
about the health impacts attractive and
more cities municipalities they engage
in what I call nuisance sweetie you just
probably spent to try tons of nuisances
whereas states anomaly I think that's
constrain municipalities but in this
case I think is delivering
because we didn't have to rebuild it too
much into Nancy pop special things about
health impacts apparently we could just
say look at the pictures right this is a
nuisance talk to me have to tell you
about how it smells when it sounds like
it doesn't belong here so we were able
to use this reduce its range
and as our local manager - really
because that was what it was all about
it was about safe neighborhoods you know
the reason I got involved so heavily
well the reason I actually said let's
build in the ban is because there was
his neighborhood after he passed his 12
underfoot stimulation that had two rigs
up one of the more than one of the
sounds that they were saying and they
were both 200 feet or so away from Hawks
one was just a couple of feet away from
where the school bus drops off when I
was out handing out flyers just a TC you
know where like they smell something and
I saw Bob Bradley their children and
running back excited is that the error
fumes coming off our survey and then
then Halloween 2013 and nobody must
retreat
and it was just I just realize how I had
to be like this I think it sort of
helped us keeping a low key thing about
state in relief I think was the
community to the halters
you're not gonna
I know about the functionary put
something
let me say maybe the last time you can
wrap up the hope framing of the book I
left out what does that looks
philosophical about this well hopefully
I've gotten some of it but I really like
is how many of you are aware the New
York state banned
hi hi mom hi mother crashing
butters is widely known
the rationale for New York's man was a
precautionary law
if you read the sort of statement that
led up to that decision it said simply
we don't know enough about the impacts
of this and so we're going to wait and
learn about in advance before we make a
decision and that's how a lot of things
there's a lot of local bands around the
country a lot of them are frankly
precautionary terms what I tried to do
in the book and I don't know if I pull
it off or not is I say look didn't the
Denton man is obviously got a
precautionary we already have 250 well
versed in the area so I'm taking this
other term which nobody knows about
called proaction air which is was made
by a bunch of transhumanists you know
these guys who want us to live forever
rate Hertz want and that you can
transform your biology team okay we're
on evolution right he's transhumanists
ed were sick of these precautionary
principle getting in the way of time
lost worth it and so they came up with
this fraction area and there's a pro
action area close to town so the
precautionary approaches treat the
technology as guilty until proven
innocent
the action approaches treat the
technology as innocent talking
and so what we do is you and roll out
then we take an opportunity and then you
monitor it and you watch it we learn
from you adapt to it I think this is the
main reason we do innovation in this
country are you trying to and the
finding of the book is that our band and
the innocent mind understanding this
kind of how I came intellectually to
terms with it every day was not about
vanity it was about giving the pro
action area model was shocked and then
recognizing there had been a family in
this case and so our band was kind of
the limits of the proaction area or this
calling out of finger correction to
technology because we weren't monitoring
it very well we weren't protecting
people or compensating people who are
made honourable to it which i think is
another condition of proaction area
edition and then they weren't able to
revise it time to make the big step
because we're locked under these little
communities so it's not an indictment
for action air approach technology in
general but it failed in the case of
them and I think that's kind of
but this looks like that's how I became
a translator
thinking of the ways I think about
technology and science Alex powers
so one
we'll be asked any questions I don't
know I guess if you have a book
[Applause]
you're watching book TV television for
serious readers watch any program you
see here online at book TV org
this is book TV on c-span - television
for serious readers here's our primetime
lineup tonight Courtney Young discusses
the politics of breastfeeding at 9:00
Mei Fong sits down for book TVs
afterwards program to talk about China's
recently discontinued one-child policy
with National Book Award winning author
Evan Osnos and that's followed at 10:00
Eastern with Catherine Olmsted and Erik
Roush way discussing the impact of FDR's
economic and social policies we wrap up
book TV in primetime at 11:00 with
Kintaro Toyama his book geek heresy
argues that technology is never the main
driver of progress that all happens
starting next on c-span 2's book TV
first
Courtney Young
afternoon and and welcome to the new
school i'm robert caslava i'm vice dean
i'm sorry i shouldn't be touching this
i'm vice dean at the New School for
Social Research and I'm really delighted
to welcome back to the University
two very dear friends and distinguished
colleagues both former members of the
politics department courtney yang and
Mallett hoon who left us about a decade
ago I think for greener or perhaps
milkier pastures of Ontario Canada and
New Mexico respectively first and
foremost I'm pleased to introduce
Courtney yang whose new book lacta vism
how feminists and fundamentalist hippies
and yuppies and physicians and
politicians made breastfeeding big
business and bad policy we are here to
celebrate the book was published last
month in November by basic books
Courtney is a professor of political
science at the University of Toronto she
holds a PhD from Yale University she has
published two previous books then I was
black and the moral force of indigenous
politics as well as a number of academic
journal articles she has been a member
at the Institute of Advanced Study in
Princeton and has received fellowships
from the National Endowment for the
Humanities Fulbright the Andrew W mellon
Foundation and the social sciences and
Humanities Research Council Canada
Courtney will give an overview for her
book of her book and then Mallett hoon
will respond with her remarks mala will
also moderate the discussion malla tun
is a professor of political science
at the University of New Mexico she's
the author of two books sex and the
state abortion divorce and the family
and the Latin American dictatorships and
democracies and inclusion without
representation gender quotas and ethnic
reservations in Latin America in 2015
she was named the an Andrew Carnegie
fellow she holds a PhD in political
science from Harvard and a B in
international relations from Stanford
before we begin I just wanted to quote
one endorsement of the book from
Courtney and mothers form a new school
colleague Nancy Fraser lab professor of
philosophy on politics
quote this riveting book charts the
constellation of unlikely bedfellows
that have together made it obligatory to
feed babies breast milk weaving a tale
of corporate profiteering and shoddy
research yuppie status mongering and
racist victim-blaming as well as
punitive policies that deny food to form
the fat children
Courtney yang explains the social forces
behind America's love affair with breast
pump not least the country's failure to
provide its workers with paid maternity
leave
eye-opening and thought-provoking lacta
vism is a master eat and cold obviously
my own experience with breastfeeding is
somewhat limited but perhaps
illustrative of Courtney's thesis as an
ant tale baby boomer born to a working
mother in communist Poland I was
breastfed for fleeting six months an
experience of deprivation symptomatic of
the times at least I was born in my son
on the other hand also born to a working
mother but
neoliberal United States was breastfed
for an extravagant you may say excessive
but certainly very long three years
eight months and 14 days in both cases
maternity leave was the same three
months so my family in a sense too is a
victim of the lack divest conspiracy so
eloquently described in the Courtney's
book and without further ado professor
Courtney Young thank you very much
Robert I I can't tell you how happy I am
to be here to be home at the new school
I'm going to fix the problem that Robert
created here there we go
thank you very much I'm so happy to be
here with a topic like this there are
many a topic like this is right for many
interesting and amusing introductory
anecdotes and contemplating those I
decided to dispense with the amusing
introductory anecdotes which almost
certainly would have been at my expense
and cut right to the chase so a lot of
people have expressed surprise that I'm
writing about breastfeeding as if this
would be a health issue or a a gender
studies issue and not a political
science issue but for me what was very
interesting about breastfeeding was the
moral fervor surrounding breastfeeding
and the surprising consensus surrounding
breastfeeding political scientists know
that consensus is not easy to find
almost anywhere consensus is a rare
thing and so when you have consensus
that seems like a reasonable thing to
study how do you get consensus where
does it come from what work does it do
in our lives so I think of this project
has base
quickly critical theory critical social
theory sort of investigating how we come
to hold the beliefs that we have and
what work those beliefs are doing in our
lives how they shape our attitudes and
how they affect our public policies and
so one place at least to start with a
project like this is to look at the
science behind breastfeeding one way of
thinking about this is is is it driven
by science is it driven by scientific
evidence and the answer to that question
is basically no or not really so all of
the research on breastfeeding is
observational that means it's not
randomized people don't conduct
randomized controlled trials into
breastfeeding and non breastfeeding
health outcomes among breastfed and non
breastfed babies and the problem with
observational research is that it has to
control for confounding variables other
things that might account for
differences between breastfed and non
breastfed babies and the older research
on breastfeeding failed to control for
confounding factors most of it failed to
control for confounding factors but
there's newer research now and it's
switch is better in many ways when you
knowing that it better defines
breastfeeding that it better controls
for confounding factors and that
evidence shows the breastfeeding has a
modest impact on the risk of infection
during the time the baby is actually
breastfeeding so it has a small impact
on the risk of infection there is good
evidence that breastfeeding has no
impact on obesity type 1 diabetes asthma
allergies and most cancers and all of
the rest of the literature on the other
long-term health outcomes that have been
attributed to or reduced risks that have
been attributed to breastfeeding is
literature the research is basically
characterized as weak and inconclusive
and this includes type 2 diabetes celiac
disease
disease cardiovascular disease blood
high blood pressure etc etc etc the list
of things that has been associated with
breastfeeding is extremely long and
almost everything on that list is well
as I say some of it has already been
pretty well disproven and the rest of it
we really don't know that literature is
weak and inconclusive so the answer to
the first question is no it is not being
driven by scientific evidence and so
that takes us back to what it is being
driven by right so for a political
scientist that becomes a really
interesting thing to study if it's not
driven by science then what is it driven
by and so one of the first part I'm
going to answer that question in three
there's sort of three pieces to the
puzzle the first piece of the puzzle is
what is breastfeeding mean to people in
the United States today and that story
starts with Lillet league in 1956 two
women Mary White and Mary Ann Thompson
were sitting together on the grass at a
Christian family movement picnic
breastfeeding their babies and lamenting
the fact that not many other people were
there breastfeeding their babies and
that mothers didn't have enough support
if they chose to breastfeed and so they
got together with five other friends and
they started La Leche League in 1956
so the centerpiece of their project was
breastfeeding but all already right at
the very inception right at the very
beginning breastfeeding was symbolic of
a larger set of philosophies which
included the mothers staying at home
nurturing the children the place of the
mother was in the family mothers should
not work once they have children and the
role of the father is as a breadwinner
so a very traditional conservative
conception of family and sort of
philosophical picture that went along
with
the width with the focus on
breastfeeding so already you have the
the rise or the the beginning of the
latest wave of breastfeeding advocacy at
using breastfeeding as a symbol for a
larger set of philosophies the next
important moment in in the history of
breastfeeding advocacy is the Nestle
boycott in the 1970s so in the 1970s
Nestle and other formula companies look
out on the developing world and see
nothing but a vast untapped market of
potential formula feeders and so they
initiate very aggressive marketing
practices in order to get women in poor
countries to buy and use formula the
most famous of those marketing practices
was the Nestle nurses they dressed their
employees up as nurses and sent them
into Hospitals and Clinics and got them
to sell got them to convince mothers to
use formula under the guise that formula
was what was medically recommended so
that's one picture these are obviously
Nestle nurses in South Africa you can
tell from the sign behind them and these
are this a whole team of Nestle
employees Nestle nurses in Malaysia in
1976 or something like that so what
happened was that Nestle is selling
formula aggressively marketing formula
in poor countries and mothers in those
poor countries are they can't afford
formula and so they're over diluting the
formula they're putting mixing it with
too much water because they can't
because they're trying to make a can of
formula last longer and so babies are
getting or becoming malnourished because
the formula is over diluted they're
essentially drinking you know colored
water water that sort of milky colored
and the second problem is that they're
using they're diluting the the powdered
formula with
with dirty water unsterilized water so
as a result of both of these things you
have a spike in infant mortality and
infant malnutrition and diarrheal
diseases and so the response to this the
solution is to reestablish breastfeeding
as the norm for infant feeding in
developing countries and so this becomes
and and so at that point you have the
Nestle boycott so the Nestle boycott is
something that happens in the United
States Canada and all over Europe and
it's very widespread it's very popular
everybody is boycotting Nestle products
in fact the Nestle boycott is the
longest and most widespread company
boycott ever people are boycotting
Nestle even today because of their
aggressive marketing practices people
boycott Nestle more often than they
boycott Philip Morris if you can believe
that
so so that's the history and it
establishes breastfeeding as a challenge
against big business in solidarity with
the global poor in solidarity with the
fight again you know the world struggle
against hunger and as I said a challenge
against corporate greed and corporate
interest so once again breastfeeding
gets appropriated right as a symbol of
something bigger a symbol of who we are
what we believe in and of the type of
person I am I'm the type of person on
the Left who challenges corporate greed
etc etc in the 1980's feminism picks up
breastfeeding so breastfeeding becomes a
symbol of female empowerment and a
symbol of the life-sustaining force of
the female body in the 1990s
breastfeeding becomes symbolic and
important important for people families
who believe in the philosophy of
attachment parenting so attachment
parents or parents who their there are
three pillars of attachment parenting
the first is
babywearing which means carrying your
baby in a sling
rather than dismissively using a
stroller to get your baby around town
the second is co-sleeping which is
sleeping in the same bed with your child
and the third is breastfeeding so
attachment parenting once again is it's
a larger philosophy breastfeeding is a
hallmark of that philosophy but it's a
larger statement about what your family
is like what your family commitments are
like and what you're like as a parent
and who you are in general maybe more
surprisingly or at least more
surprisingly to me
breastfeeding has been embraced by the
Christian right so for many on the
Christian Right breastfeeding turns out
to be proof of intelligent design and it
also offers evidence of the rightness of
heterosexual marriage with different
roles for men and women in in the
marriage and it's also been picked up as
an issue for environmentalists and for
people who believe in locally locally
produced sustainable food because after
all what could be more locally produced
than breast milk so for all of these
groups of people many of whom are
actually fundamentally opposed to one
another wouldn't see eye to eye on
practically any other issue across the
social and political spectrum and yet
they all believed in breastfeeding and
the point that I'm showing is that they
all believe in breastfeeding for
fundamentally different reasons they've
they've appropriated the symbol of
breastfeeding but for many many
different reasons this is this is the
the power point I was supposed to show
with the attachment parenting many of
you will remember this Time magazine
cover of this attachment parent
breastfeeding her son who's three or
four years old and maybe not
coincidentally wearing camouflage pants
I thought that was the most sort of
disquiet in part of the whole
sure was the camouflage pants all right
so that's the first I did actually um he
doesn't he looks old and big anyway so
that's the first part of the puzzle
that's the first part of the picture
which is the ways in which breastfeeding
has taken on symbolic meaning and how
much value and some symbolic value it
has for so many people breastfeeding
isn't all things to all people but it is
a surprising number of things to a
surprising number of people the second
part of the puzzle or the second piece
of the puzzle is actually has to do not
surprisingly with business there's a
there's a business angle to this which
is surprising to those of us who still
associate the business of infant feeding
with the business of the big formula
companies so the idea here is that
breastfeeding is free that was long the
challenge against breastfeeding and yet
it's actually far from free in 21st
century America and the first reason
it's far from free is that if you ever
plan to leave the house you're going to
have to buy some clothes and some bras
and you might need some nutritional
supplements to make sure that you have a
good milk supply and then you need
pillows and shields and creams and all
kinds of other things it's not necessary
to buy any of these things but most
people who breastfeed in the United
States today will buy many of these
things the second component of the
business of breastfeeding is lactation
consultants most women who breastfeed
will see a lactation consultant at some
point in their breastfeeding career and
that will run you anywhere from 200 to
500 dollars an hour so there's an entire
industry of lactation consultants who
are making their living off of
breastfeeding
and the final component of the business
of breastfeeding is the breast pump
industry in the United States in 2007
people did a really large study on
pumping and breastfeeding and they
discovered that 85% of American women
who breastfeed were also pumping that's
an enormous percentage of the population
and and it explains why 40 percent of
the world market for breast pumps is an
American market there's nowhere else in
the world where women are breast pumping
pumping breast milk as much as they are
in the United States and so in the next
few years the world market the world
breast pump market is expected to reach
2.6 billion dollars annually and as I
said 40 percent of that market is in the
United States and all of this pumping
creates something that is new in the
history of humankind which is a surplus
of human milk building up in the
refrigerators and freezers of American
women I won't say anymore building up in
the refrigerators and freezers of
American women so what happens here is
there's been the the combination of the
internet and the pump has revolutionized
wet-nursing
so as we're as wet-nursing used to be a
service a woman would take your baby and
nurse your baby now it's a product a
product that is sold online routinely oh
this is a good image I need to step back
here a minute lest you think that the
Nestle nurses are a thing of the past
this is a store on the Upper East Side
of Manhattan called yummy mummy and the
owner of the store is in the middle with
the long blonde hair and the people
surrounding her are not nurses the ones
dressed in white lab coats they're her
employees and they're dressed in white
lab coats as
to sell all of the things that they sell
in their breastfeeding store like
pillows and nutritional supplements and
pumps so the the phenomenon of the
dressing people up as nurses in order to
convince people that the way we're
recommending that you feed your baby is
medically sanctioned this is not
actually a dead phenomenon it's alive
and well right here in Manhattan so this
is um so as a result of all of this
pumping and as a result of the of the
surplus of human milk what we have in
the United States is a thriving human
market human milk market a thriving
market in human milk so the most common
website where people buy and sell milk
is called only the breasts and these are
for ads I took from only the breast just
yesterday so all of this breast milk is
still available probably if you want
some of it so people buy and sell breast
milk any day of the week you can see
between twelve and sixteen thousand
posts at only the breast for people who
are wanting to buy or sell breast milk
and it's not only mothers looking to
feed their babies who are buying human
milk or breast milk online athletes are
buying breast milk and consuming it in
in large numbers it's a common
phenomenon because they're looking to
boost their performance and a lot of
people are interested in eating breast
milk because they're or drinking breast
milk because they're thinking of it is
the new superfood you know it's better
than wheatgrass and so they're looking
to boost their immunity or whatever
they're looking to do so there's a big
market in human milk and so these people
other people who who sell their breast
milk are not necessarily selling online
to other mothers and other individuals
of people sell their breast milk to
companies so there's a company in
California called prolactin bo science
that buys breast milk for a dollar an
ounce and they turn it into they use it
as a raw material in the production of
nutritional supplements so they they buy
the breast milk for a dollar an ounce
they turn it into or it's the the base
of a nutritional supplement and then
they sell those nutritional supplements
for a hundred and eighty dollars an
ounce no this is a private company
prolactin so they don't disclose what
their profits are every year but they
have disclosed that they have received
46 million dollars in venture capital in
the last couple of years and this is a
growing industry there are prolactin is
the oldest company in this niche market
but it's not the only one there are six
or seven other companies that are
competing with prolactin to to produce
to produce things like nutritional
supplements different kinds of
nutritional supplements but at the base
the raw material of all of them is the
is the is the human milk and so one of
the things that's interesting about this
is companies like Medela which is the
largest breast pump manufacturer in the
world and prolactin bioscience which is
also making money off in off of human
milk both of these corporations fund
research into the chemical properties of
human milk so not which is which is a
new line of research so not long ago
people who were interested in
breastfeeding and who knew something
about who were breastfeeding experts and
who studied breastfeeding they were
breastfeeding researchers and they went
to conferences on breastfeeding medicine
and they studied breastfeeding now they
study human lactation and they go to
conferences that are call
old things like innovations in human
lactation and there are laboratories
there's a laboratory in Western
Australia that's funded by Medela the
entire lab is funded by Medela at
University of Western Australia and it's
a human lactation lab it's actually run
by a guy who specializes in cow and pig
lactation and now this is just human
lactation so he moves his expertise in
cow and pig lactation neatly into the
human lactation sphere so one of the
things I think that's compelling here is
that all of this pumping is producing a
not only are people making money now in
the breastfeeding sector but they're
there they have a vested interest in
making sure that the breastfeeding
sector is not outside of the market
right that it's drawn into the market
and and that the the the premise of all
of this has to be that what is valuable
about breastfeeding is not the
mother-child interaction at the breast
but instead the consumption of human
milk right so it's driving this whole
new line of research into the
consumption of human milk transforming
how it is that we understand what counts
as breastfeeding transforming
breastfeeding into human milk
consumption and this in turn is driving
public policy and advocacy advocacy
initiatives so President Obama has been
well known for launching a number of
breastfeeding advocacy initiatives in
the last in during his administrations
and so at a federal level these federal
kinds of initiatives are unusual they
haven't been there haven't been
presidents before who have been
launching breastfeeding initiatives but
the interesting thing about these
initiatives is that
a single one of them has anything to do
with breastfeeding all of them are in
fact about pumping so in 2011 the Fair
Labor Standards Act was reformed to
require employees to provide space and
unpaid work breaks to new mothers so
they could pump up work in 2012 the IRS
amended the tax codes who allow others
to take tax deductions for pumps and in
2013 that was superseded when the
affordable care act was reformed to
require insurance companies to cover the
cost of breast pumps for all new mothers
so suddenly in January 2013
all new mothers in the United States
were were entitled to receive a free new
breast pump and so obviously that 85%
figure that was quoted in 2007 is now
much closer to a hundred percent because
American mothers are getting free breast
pumps when they when they have a baby so
long as they're insured Medicaid is also
required to give to give mothers free
breast pumps so what all of this is
doing is of course reframing or
expectations of what new mothers are
supposed to do to feed their babies not
long ago we thought of working and
breastfeeding as mutually exclusive you
could either work or you could
breastfeed but you would not really be
expected to do both not anymore now
women are expected to lug a pump back
and forth to work and pump breast milk
during unpaid work breaks often in
unused room and supply closets or filthy
locker rooms and conference rooms so
there's a tremendous burden being placed
on women from the advent from this the
breast pump phenomenon the the ubiquity
of breast pumps from all of these
initiatives that are promoting breast
pumping rather than promoting breast
feeding I wanted to show you this other
image as well
in 2012 New York City implemented the
what became a controversial
breastfeeding advocacy program the latch
on New York City program and this was
the advertising campaign that
accompanied latch on NYC and you see
that this advertising campaign doesn't
actually mention breastfeeding at all
it's all about breast milk as a product
and in fact I interviewed the direct in
New York City director of health the
health commissioner under Bloomberg
named dr. Thomas Farley and I said to
him why did you just refer to breast
milk in those posters why didn't you
talk about breastfeeding at all and he
said we're thinking about breast milk as
a product and then he said and you know
if we'd said breastfeeding that would
have been much too hard for most mothers
to do most mothers in New York returned
to work after they have a baby and they
don't have maternity leave and
breastfeeding actually requires too much
of a change in the workplace and
remember he said I was the public health
commissioner under Mayor Bloomberg and
Mayor Bloomberg of course is well known
for being business friendly and I
couldn't possibly be advancing a an
advocacy campaign that implied that
businesses would have to bear the cost
of this breastfeeding through maternity
leave right this was not a way of
getting maternity leave so there was an
explicit decision made to talk about
breast milk rather than breastfeeding in
this advocacy campaign so that's the
second slice into this the question of
you know what's the deal with
breastfeeding why the moral fervor
surrounding breastfeeding and then
finally I want to swing around to the
third part of my
sir and here I argue the breastfeeding
Maxon - and reinforces many of the
divisions that have long fractured
American society and in particular I'm
concerned about divisions of race and
class so every year the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention publish
what they call the annual breastfeeding
report card and when they so that's data
on who's breastfeeding in the United
States how common it is etc and so then
they break down that data and they break
it down by state and they also break it
down by demographic differences and the
demographic differences that they use to
to sort of slice through their data are
differences of race class so the
differences are race socioeconomic
status marital status and level of
education and by by organizing their
data that way what they show year upon
year is that women who are white in
higher socioeconomic have a higher
socioeconomic status are married and are
what are the what's the fourth thing
have higher levels of education thank
you
those are the women who are
breastfeeding and the women who are
supposedly failing to breastfeed are
women who are african-american poor
unmarried and and undereducated have a
high school or less level of education
so annually when the breastfeeding
report card comes out this is a story
that gets picked up in newspapers across
the United States you will see this
story every single year and the story is
always the exact same story the story is
breastfeeding rates are improving but
African Americans still lag far behind
and this is presented as coming from a
place of concern concern over the poor
african-american babies that are not
receiving the benefits of breast milk
but in a country with the kind of
history and the kind of present reality
of racial division that information is
also shoring up the status of white
people as better parents and when
breastfeeding is turned into a public
health issue so in 2012 the American
Academy of Pediatrics the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention and the
United States Surgeon General decided
that breastfeeding had become a public
health issue and the reason it was a
public health issue was that the failure
to breastfeed was costing the United
States thirteen billion dollars per year
the thirteen billion dollars number is a
result of a very of a widely published
study but one that I could tell you
about later if you're interested why
that thirteen billion dollar number is
perhaps inflated at any rate so the
United States identifies breastfeeding
as a public health issue in 2012 and
what happens then is by identifying it
as a public health issue and saying the
failure to breastfeed is costing the
United States thirteen billion dollars
per year the CDC the AAP etc they
transform those people who were just bad
parents before into irresponsible
citizens basically costing the United
States billions and billions of dollars
per year in unnecessary infections and
diseases and conditions and illnesses
which they could easily be preventing if
only they would breastfeed their
children so the problem here is that the
problem here is that breastfeeding fits
to the way that this information is
presented the way the data is presented
reinforces it maps on to and it
reinforces all of the or many of the
divisions and prejudices that have long
been fracturing American society so for
middle and upper class women and it
creates policies that are in turn really
problematic as well it-it-it justifies
what are called